when rereading the Harry Potter books or
watching the movies it's harder to
stumble upon little inconsistencies here
and there from limited career options to
the logistics of Polyjuice potion these
are just a few Harry Potter details that
don't make sense
after a young witch or wizard graduates
from Hogwarts they're expected to join
the adult Wizarding World and part of
that is figuring out which career works
for them
join the fifth book in the series order
of the Phoenix Harry visits Professor
McGonagall for a required career advice
meeting and they discuss which classes
Harry should take to qualify phase two
zayed post-grad job however besides
becoming an aura a dark wizard catcher
post Hogwarts options seem pretty scarce
especially according to the adults in
Harry's life it's never revealed what
Harry's parents James and Lily did for a
living but almost every adult he knows
growing up either works for the
Wizarding government the Ministry of
Magic or teachers our Hogwarts though
there is a Wizarding hospital st.
Mungo's which is stocked with healers
and some talented athletes might become
Quidditch players this means there are
roughly four viable career paths in the
Wizarding World a stage play Harry
Potter and the cursed child which serves
the sorts of sequel to the original
series seems to confirm the lack of
career options as adults Harry Ron and
Hermione are all employed by the
ministry with Hermione even serving a
term as a minister of magic in Harry sir
tiara Hogwarts he discovers the
Marauders map an enchanted moving map of
Hogwarts that details every secret
passageway contains every room and shows
a user where every single person within
the castle is and whether or not they're
on the move a password protected cheat
sheet to the school the map is immensely
useful to Harry throughout his time at
Hogwarts and beyond and as it turns out
it was his birthright all along how his
father James helped create the map
during his own time there I solemnly
swear that I am up to no good
Harry has given the map by Ron's
brothers Fred and George the notoriously
mischievious Weasley twins who have been
its custodians for years but this seems
a bit off considering that map
apparently contained a huge conspicuous
secret the entire time they had it Peter
Pettigrew one of the Maps creators and
the man who portrayed how his parents
spend 12 years posing as Ron's pet rats
and sharing a dorm room with Ron
hurry and apparently Fred and George
didn't pay much attention to the strange
name hanging out with their brother for
years the twins may be troublemakers but
they're not stupid it just doesn't add
up one notable feature of Hogwarts is
that is filled with magical moving
portraits and students and professors
alike can communicate with the seemingly
sentient subjects were then from the
portrait of the fat lady who guards a
Gryffindor common room to the former
headmasters and had mistresses living in
their own commemorative portraits and
the more doors office this world is
filled with painted personalities who
are fully capable of carrying on
conversations with anyone who tries to
talk to them password cabbage Draconis
[Music]
though Harry never directly learns the
rules of portraits it seems as if
they're only created when a wizard dies
after Dumbledore's death in half-blood
Prince his portrait appears alongside
his predecessors and Headmaster's office
and as it turns out he dispenses advice
to Severus Snape who takes up the post
in the seventh book even so the exact
mechanics of these magical port rates
remain bafflingly unclear there's
definitely some part of the person
within the portraits but does it only
contain the knowledge they possess until
their death or can the port traits
continue to evolve every portrait how he
encounters seems to be able to process
and learn new information making the
concept all the more confusing naturally
the magic behind this went unexplained
throughout the series our encounters
plenty of action and adventure during
his time in Hogwarts which seems par for
the course for a kid constantly evading
the most dangerous Dark Wizard of all
time as a result he also encounters
plenty of injuries from regrowing all of
the bones in his arm to recovering from
deadly curses the medical staff at
Hogwarts is usually on high alert and
the school nurse Madame Pomfrey is
capable of mending broken bones in the
blink of an eye but damn Pomfrey skills
extend beyond life and death
circumstances as well
when hermione ends up cursed with
expanding teeth the nurse shrinks them
so that they're cosmetically perfect
even though Hermione's teeth weren't
perfect before she was hit with a curse
with that being said it's a little odd
that so many characters in Harry's world
including Harry himself wear glasses if
Madame Pomfrey or any healer at st.
Mungo's can cure poison snake bites and
broken legs why can they fix something
as simple as a stigmatism one of the
most interesting potions and the
wizarding world is Polyjuice potion a
brew that allows a user to transform
into any other person for one hour as
long as they have a bit of that person
which in Harry's experience typically
means a hair or two from the person's
head in Harry's second year he and Ron
impersonate together in students Crabbe
and Goyle to figure out if Harry's
nemesis Draco Malfoy is using the
Chamber of Secrets to attack muggle-born
students why he wearing glasses
ah um reading reading what to make of
read then in Harry's fourth year it
turns out that one of his professors is
not the actual or Amara Moody but a
Death Eater pretending to be Moody
thanks to the potion despite the
difficult brewing process Polyjuice
potion is a constant factor throughout
Harry's journey
if Polyjuice potion seems too good to be
true you're right
there are any number of problems a user
could encounter while using it
beyond Hermione accidentally using a
cat's hair in the Chamber of Secrets and
ending up in the hospital wing even if
you look exactly like the person you're
impersonating anyone who knows them well
enough would likely notice if your
mannerisms are off the entire situation
could be blown wide open when someone
whose hair has been used for Polyjuice
suddenly doesn't remember conversations
or experiences they had with other
people Polyjuice might seem foolproof
but it's far from it you're lying
Dolores
and one mustn't tell light
to check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
[Applause]